By far the hardest thing I experienced as a mom of kids who are, like,
9 and 8 is the constant fighting between each other.
Like, I remember this from when I was a kid,
but, like,
when my sister would breathe a certain way or, like,
look out my window of the car,
it was like nails on a chalkboard, and I wanted to punch her face in.
That's just sibling stuff, right?
Never had I ever thought how physically annoying
that probably was to my parents,
but now I get it.
Now I get it. And don't get me wrong,
my two older kids get along,
are best friends,
like, hate to be separated,
but they also never leave each other's, like,
personal space bubble.
So much so that they have now asked to have a joint boy girl room
where they can sleep in the same room together.
So, like,
their buds, these are not like fights.
These are more like,
let me poke and see how you much you can take.
But you know who can't take it?
You know who can't take it anymore?
Me! Referee.
Parenting requires all the patience.